[Music]
she told some people you're in trouble
and she's going over town and collected
all the money you got everything you
need it's wonderful George - George
Bailey the richest man in town
[Music]
this is only like four hundred and
thirteen dollars well how much money do
you need George a thousand dollars well
surely we can raise enough how about
everyone gives another dollar hey it's
only like 17 more dollars we're almost
there
[Music]
all right come on couldn't you just give
a little more when I have this ten
dollar beer I'll just take six singles
back and that's almost $8,000 on the
nose what you've done okay I make change
with this money I have an idea let's
have a bake sale will make teeny-tiny
pies charge 10 cents a pie ha I bet we
could make a hundred pies even I love
that's only ten dollars well how do you
figure math do you people know how money
works yes 1 2 3 4 5 6 you go this is a
plastic nickel I got the nickels I don't
even know you
I'm Cecil let's see some old Cecil
George we've met you're a stranger to me
George why do we have married settle
something for pretty pretty hair I'm not
gonna do that quiet everybody a telegram
from your rich friend Sam George stop my
office is instructed to advance you up
to $25,000 oh stop he hard Merry
Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
there's more I just need you to wait 12
weeks for a check to clear stop
hee-haw and Merry Christmas I'm gonna
tell the night George I'll pay $400 for
her hair but that's twice as much as I
usually pay for house with the hair it's
Christmas we all can do whatever we like
to do with it sniff it and lick it
stop can't any of you small town idiots
give me anything else uh I guess we
gotta arrest you now alright let's go oh
it's in between my fingers hey I guess
we should just take back on money right
that's cool
Clarence my guardian angel hi here you
go George whoa what is that
and haven't we use clouds as money
clouds are worth nothing to me Clarence
I need $8,000 grand what that's what I
was trying to tell you on the bridge you
dumb angel
[Music]
you